the aaron rodgers saga continues that's
a tweet from
james jones everyone relax r-e-l-a-x
that's one of the
aaron rodgers catch phrases not nearly
as entertaining as don't waste your time
reading that crap
um james jones was on nfl network
explaining the
comments from mark murphy the
complicated fella
line this isn't a conspiracy please take
that down people
people think that's actually me um
it's not photoshopped i like it so
they're telling that's what they think
the rest of your body looks like
my here's my theory and and this is the
the
best i could do with what james jones
had to say
james jones despite some
internal inconsistencies in his words as
he was explaining his beliefs because i
think he's trying to walk a very fine
line here between not
pissing off mark murphy who he claims to
have a good relationship and not pissing
off aaron rodgers
who jones clearly has a good
relationship with by virtue of the fact
that rogers actually
speaks to jones the the logic
goes like this it's not complicated if
you have a good relationship with him so
you need to have a good relationship
with him if you have a good relationship
with him it won't be complicated you can
work this out
and it dawned on me as i was trying to
make sense of what james jones had to
say on nfl network last night that
that aaron rodgers quite possibly
wants the packers and specifically mark
murphy
to reach out to jones and have
jones serve as the liaison
as the go-between as the middle man
between management
and player because jones has said it's
fixable
he said last week it's fixable last
night he says it's complicated if you
don't have the relationship with aaron
rodgers
well he's got the relationship with
rogers and the relationship with murphy
and i think if rogers is going to get
whatever it is that he wants and last
week jones says well
he doesn't want brian guticun's fired
and he doesn't want this he doesn't want
this i'm not telling you what he wants
but he doesn't want all these other
things which is just
irritating don't tell me what he doesn't
want tell me what he does want if
you want it to to be understood by the
fan base
but i i can't help but feel like rogers
is looking for
a face saver here something that allows
him to come back
something and that maybe jones can be
the guy who
who bridges the gap between murphy slash
good accounts
and quarterback well i agree with you i
agree with you in a lot of ways
i i don't know if i buy like the um the
middle man
like murphy and guten koos are going to
talk to james jones to sue this over
but like i i agree with you i think in
the fact that
i mean this aaron rodgers is giving
these messages to him
to send them out into the public and
that's him speaking
you know so he's playing at that angle
he's getting his messages out there like
i don't know what is there to mend
anymore with rogers and that it's
over he don't like you they don't like
him
i doesn't look like i don't know but it
definitely looks like he doesn't like
them
i can say that and so it's like okay
you know and we've talked about there's
no issues with the rest of the
organization
so i think it's more about like these
these things are more about
kind of mending public perception and
and more about
getting that that that notice out there
to the green bay
fans and things like that to calm them
down and also set the stage for
yes him coming to training camp and uh
getting ready to play football
i you know i just had this this
this flash through my brain and recently
it was the 35 year anniversary of the
release
of ferris bueller's day off it's almost
like
aaron rodgers is ferris bueller and mark
murphy is rooney the principal
rooney and i just i just think
i i should say you do does that far
better than i ever did but i
i think and as more time goes by
i think i think rooney doesn't want
ferris in school anymore i
really think that murphy doesn't want
him to show up doesn't want to trade him
yeah
but but he's basically daring him
goading him
to stay away and i think murphy secretly
would love it
it seems that way i mean it does and you
know maybe that's where
that's where again i think all the
hubbub and everything of yesterday and
all
that's where we got into the james jones
relax thing
because everybody was talking about it
again and he probably knew he was gonna
have to go on tv
and talk about it or say something so he
texts aaron rodgers what should i say
i'm gonna have to make a comment
and rogers you know he's aware enough to
know that everybody was talking about
you know the complicated fella bullcrap
thing that mark murphy said the other
day
so he comes back with the relax thing so
he's the sounding board for rogers at
least the way it looks like for me but
like
i'm with you mike i don't know i mean
yeah after that like we said yesterday i
mean
it looked like mark murphy is like he's
he's trying to
piss rogers off more and really dare him
not to come
daring him not to come because if he
doesn't show up for training camp he
will be
the bad guy even though there was some
rancor
that dusted up after murphy's comments
came to light and some fans were upset
that murphy was gratuitously stirring
the pot
if rogers doesn't show up for training
camp with three years left on his
contract
he will be i think based on
the preponderance of the reaction he
will be the villain
in this because the fans always fall in
line behind the laundry
that's the way it works and it shouldn't
be that way
but it is and they're not going to be
shot well they may be showing up to the
shareholders meeting
in aaron rodgers jerseys but it's not
going to be in aaron rodgers denver
broncos jerseys they're going to be
wearing packers
gear they are packers fans and they've
gone from bart starr
to brett favre to aaron rodgers and yeah
there was a lot of crap in the 20 years
between
star and favre but they are through and
through packers fans and they know that
rogers is going to be there for much
longer anyway
they're gonna they're gonna stay in line
behind the team that they own a piece of
yeah that's one of the benefits of
selling
stock in your team you are part
of the organization that's not that it
was
done for that purpose that's the
ultimate pr
lever against a dis in a dispute with a
player
if you own a piece of the team you're
already you've already picked a side
you're already on the side of management
you are management
well yeah but you could also have a big
stake in that team and go man
this steak would be a lot worth a whole
lot more if they would just do something
to give this guy a chance to win the
damn super bowl
and then watch my stock prices go up so
they might be sitting there going
yeah i'm management but the guys that
are really managing
are messing up my damn checkbook and
everything like that too
stock prices don't go up can't sell the
stock that's the weirdest thing about
green bay packs
it makes no sense sell it the value
doesn't change
it is it is a great
and unique other than the fact that
there's you know
tens of thousands of these out there but
it's a piece of memorabilia you put it
in a frame you put it on the wall
there's my share
will green bay pack will it ever happen
like you think eddie like does like jeff
bezos come in one day
like screw you i'm buying all you out
it's 10 billion you can't
even do it how do you round them all up
i don't know i just started throwing it
out there i don't know yeah
yeah all right i i i just i think the
way they've set it up
no one can buy that no i can do it it is
uniquely held by the people who buy it
directly from the packers
so that no one can go out and buy it all
up and take control of the team
it really is a strange thing and the one
the one thing that it does for the
purposes of those who wonder how
profitable the nfl is every year because
it's publicly traded even though it's
not traded
it's publicly held we get to see the
books yeah and it gives us an idea of
what all the teams
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports